[Music]
you've probably seen it footage of the
labour leader kiestama being bundled
into a police car as protesters shouted
traitor and jimmy savile at him
here's everything you need to know about
those videos exactly what happened right
here in westminster and how the prime
minister boris johnson fits in
this is the moment on monday evening
when kirstama was mobbed by anti-covert
vaccine protesters outside parliament
shouting jimmy savile and accusing him
of protecting pedophiles
so what's jimmy savile got to do with
this well the bbc presenter was a
prolific pedophile but the details of
his six decades of abuse only became
widely known after his death he was
never brought to justice
before kiestama entered politics he ran
the crown prosecution service and was in
charge of bringing criminal prosecutions
in england and wales that was at the
same time jimmy savile's crimes came to
light
[Music]
the video of the labour leader being
mobbed came exactly one week after the
prime minister accused sakir of failing
to prosecute jimmy savile during his
time as director of public prosecutions
a former director of public prosecutions
mr speaker
he spent most of his time prosecuting
journalists and failing to prosecute
jimmy savile this is what kiestama said
in response it is a ridiculous slur
peddled by right-wing trolls other mps
from across the commons criticize mr
johnson's comments we're better than
this we you know we must seek to improve
our standards and not uh and rise above
where we are today even some of his own
cabinet ministers have distanced
themselves with regard to their comments
and you know being being honest i
wouldn't have said it and although the
pm clarified his comments i totally
understand that he had nothing to do
personally with those decisions he has
refused to apologize i was making a
point
about
um
the his responsibility for the
organization
as a whole so is there any truth behind
the claims
fact-checkers have rejected the claim
kierstarma failed to prosecute jimmy
savile there is no evidence he was
involved in any of the charging
decisions but zakir did apologize for
his organization's failure to bring the
pedophile to justice and the labour
leader has accused boris johnson of
using fascist conspiracy theories to try
and win political points
now their leader stands in the house of
commons parroting the conspiracy
theories of violent fascists to try and
score cheap political points
one of the pm's own advisors has quit
over these comments
policy chief manira merza said it was
desperately sad that boris johnson had
made such a scurrilous accusation she
called it an inappropriate and partisan
reference to a horrendous case of child
sexual abuse
but number 10 has doubled down on the
pm's remarks
they insist that while mr johnson was
not personally accusing kiestama of
failing to prosecute savile this was a
question of leadership and sakia did
lead the cps
so what has the prime minister said
about this new video he has condemned
the protesters actions as absolutely
disgraceful and said
all forms of harassment of our elected
representatives are completely
unacceptable
but even though there is no evidence the
protesters targeted the labour leader
because of the pm's comments
even the speaker of the commons has
connected mr johnson's words with the
actions of those protesters these sorts
of comments only inflame opinions and
generate disregard for the house and it
is not acceptable
our words have consequences and we
should always be mindful of that fight
so what does this mean for the prime
minister who's already had a rocky few
weeks
boris johnson was trying to move on from
the party gate row attempting to reset
his government's agenda but this fracar
has only reignited the row over his
character he was already in a fragile
position and all this has only made it
worse